ladies and gentlemen the star of
clueless of this year's Silverstone
when you're on location
sitting on a folding chair at 5:00 a.m.
staring at your reflection in a coffee
urn your fate is probably in the hands
of a makeup artist whether it's
improving on reality or creating fantasy
through the years the Wizards of makeup
who dazzled us with their powers of
transformation using special wigs facial
extensions and an array of waxes powders
and brushes a makeup artist scopes a
rich world of amazing effects and
believable characters from aging an
actor 30 years to sewing stitches makeup
artists provide an amazing jour de force
of Hollywood invention and creativity
for best achievement and makeup the
nominees are for Braveheart Peter
Frampton Paul Patterson and Lois Burwell
for my family meet Amelia Ken Diaz and
Mark Sanchez
for roommates greg cannom Bob Layden and
Colleen Callahan and the Oscar is
awarded to Peter Frampton Paul Pattinson
I love us for a while for Braveheart
you
well just just a few words of thanks of
course to Mel for making such a fabulous
film which got all our work noticed and
a few absent friends in the makeup bus
that can't be here this evening
- Amanda Knight the best assistant
anybody could have - Beryl Lerman my
other assistant - Francesca Crowder and
- Susan love in the hair department and
on a another note all the Irish boys and
girls that for months slaughter people
in the field of battle up to the neck in
modern bullets slightly more personal
note Braveheart has been my last film
after 28 years I take this with great
honor and pride back to Australia thank
you so much thank you very much
that didn't look like Peter Frampton
I love your ways too baby